لأنك كنت في قلبي ، قال إنها كانت
ممرضة تدعى
سيرجيو هيرنانديز تعاقدت مع كوبن 19
بعد محاولتها إنقاذ آخرين
بالفيروس ، قام سيرجيو بعمل هذا الفيديو لطمأنة
عائلته بأنه سيكون على ما يرام
وبعد ساعات فقط ذهب  في
ألبرتو هيرنانديز هو ابن عم سيرجيو ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكونك معنا ،
أنا آسف جدًا لخسارتك ،
ما كان سيرجيو أعني حقيقة
أنه
اعتنى بأمه عندما
كانت مريضة وعاد إلى  المستشفى
حيث تعاقد بعد ذلك ، أعني أنه
لا بد أنه كان مكرسًا بشكل لا يصدق ،
لقد كان أه أحب الحياة ، لقد أحب
الحياة المعيشية التي
تسافر لرعاية ابنه
وعائلته ، لقد كان رجلًا عائليًا
ولكنه أيضًا رجل يحب الخدمة
وأحبها  لمساعدة الآخرين
كما قلت إنه كان في المنزل مع أخته
ووالدته حيث كان يقاتل للأسف
خسرت أخته معركتها وخرجت والدته عمتي
منها بالكاد
وبعد إرضاعهم في المنزل
قرر المخاطرة بحياته
أم  لمساعدة الآخرين  يقاتل كوفيد في
نفس المستشفى لدرجة أنه سينتهي به الأمر
وأعلم أن الكثير من عائلتك يعيشون في
كاليفورنيا.
ماتت أخته من كوبنهاغن في أغسطس أم لا ، أعني
أن الفيروس قد أثر
على عائلتك ،
نعم ، في أواخر شهر يوليو ، كانت كلتا
أخته توأمتين وتعاقدت والدته مع
كوفيد في أواخر يوليو وخسرت أخته
معركتها في أغسطس  الثامن وهكذا
استمر في مساعدة والدته من
خلال كل ما يساعد عائلته ومن
ثم
الأخت الأخرى لحسن الحظ
ونجت ابنتها ونجت عمتي
ولكن ذلك كان له أثر كبير عليها
جسديًا وطبعًا
عاطفياً وبقي في المنزل وكان شديدًا
كان مفيدًا وساعدها في إرضاعها إلى حالتها
الصحية النسبية ، ثم في
سبتمبر / أيلول ، أريد أن أقول يوم 14 سبتمبر / أيلول
، عاد للعمل في الخطوط
الأمامية بالمستشفى
حيث توفيت أخته
وكانت والدته  غادر
وعاد دون تردد إلى العمل
وخدمة الآخرين ولم يكن
صحيحًا بعد أكثر من شهر من ذلك في
22 أكتوبر ، كانت نتيجة اختباره
إيجابية وبحلول 6 نوفمبر كان قد مات.